نعم في موقع جديد وتفاصيل جديده هنا
فرقاطه عسكريه هنديه للتو وصلت الى ميناء
جده الاسلامي لكن هذه المره تحديدا على
هذه السفينه هي تحمل رعايه من الهند قادمه
من السودان للتو وصلت هذه السفينه هي
تعتبر السفينه الثالثه بالنسبه لكسفينه
عسكريه هنديه تقف على هذا الرصيف اجمالي
ما قامت بانزالا من رعايه الهند حتى الان
لهذه السفن يتجاوزون 800 شخص هذه السفينه
تحديدا تحمل
326 وهم في اللحظات الاخيره او اللحظات ما
قبل الاخيره ليتم اعطاء الاذن من ايضا
التوجيه الارضي حتى يتم انزالهم بسلام
وامان هنا ايضا في الجانب الاخر على
الرصيف تحديدا ريثما يتم التحضير لانزال
هؤلاء الركاب اجهزه امنيه وكذلك قطاعات
عسكريه وايضا جهاز حكوميه هم في استقبالهم
حرس الحدود السعوديه وكذلك قطاعات من
القوات البحريه الملكيه السعوديه وايضا
ادارات الجمارك وجهاد حكوميه وقائد وحده
امن المينا في حرس الحدود العقيد ركن عبد
الله القحطاني في مقدمه استقبالها هؤلاء
الركاب وكذلك كما نشاهد ايضا مجندات
سعوديات وهذا هو الجسر الذي سوف يتم انزال
في هذا الركاب طبعا دعنا عادل
على هذه السفينه راح نتعرف لكن بس اذا
سمحتي يعني ال 500 نحن نتحدث عن اكثر من
800 من رعايه الهند ذكرت انهم قدموا الى
السعوديه في عمليه الاجلاء ما هي الخطوه
الثانيه بعد اجراء اهم ريثما ان نبقى معك
في الصوره ونشاهد لربما ايضا تكون عمليه
انزال
الرعايه الرعايه الهند من هذه السفينه اين
يذهبون وبالتالي كيف يتم التصرف معهم في
الخطوه المقبله
بينما يتم عمليه تجهيز انزانهم سوف نبدا
نتحدث عن المرحله الثانيه طبعا بعد انزال
الركاب وهم سواء من الهند او كذلك
الجنسيات الاخرى التي كانت تاتي على
فرقاطات او سفن عسكريه سواء نتحدث عن
الصينيه او كذلك عن الفرنسيه او عن سفن
التجاريه المعظم لا يحمل تاشيره الدخول
الى السعوديه هنا ياتي دور الجوازات
السعوديه التي تمنحهم تاشيرات سريعه
وطارئه حتى يتمكنون من دخول الى السعوديه
وكذلك
مغادرتها بعد التنسيق مع سفراتهم
وقنصلياتهم التي تقوم
بانهاء اجراءاتهم مع الحكومه السعوديه حتى
يتم مغادرتهم الى بلدانهم بامان وسلام بعد
نزولهم وايضا يتم او يتم انتقالهم الى
الحافلات المخصصه ونشاهد الحافلات ويلتقط
المصور وهو اجمل ويكون حركته سريعه بشكل
افضل ويلتقط هذه الصور سوف تتضح لنا
الحافلات التي سوف يتم صعود عليها الركاب
سواء من رعايه الهند او كذلك الجنسيات
المختلفه الذين ياتون عبر السفن
والفرقاطات العسكريه او كذلك السفن
التجاريه وبعد ذلك يتم انهاء اجراءات عبر
الجوازات السعوديه وبعدها يتم انتقالهم
الى مقر اقامه يتهيا لهم او فنادق تم
تهيئتها لهم داخل مدينه جده البعض طبعا
يتم مغادرته مباشره او يتجه مباشره الى
مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي في مدينه
جده هناك طائرات جهزت وتم تهيئتها
واستعدادها من قبل القنصليات او السفاره
تحديدا على هذه الرحله هي الهنديه والجزء
الاخر يتم مغادرته خلال اليومين القادمين
بعد عمليه الاستعداد وتجهيزات المحضره لهم
حتى يتم وصولهم بسلام عموما لدينا ايضا
وصول هنا وزير الدوله لشونا الخارجيه
الهنديه يصل في هذه اللحظات الذي سوف يكون
ايضا في استقبال رعايه الهند او الركاب
القادمين من السودان هذا هو وزير الدوله
للشؤون الخارجيه الهنديه وهذه الصور
الاولى التي يتم التقاطها عبر شاشه
العربيه لوصول وزير الدوله للشؤون
الخارجيه الهندي وكذلك الان
بينما
بينما هو يصل سوف تبدا عمليه انزال الركاب
من داخل السفينه طبعا ما زلنا نقوم او
مازلنا ننتظر وصول او نزول الركاب نحاول
الصعود معهم
ناخذ هذه اللقطات
طيب نحن معك بالتاكيد يعني نتمنى ان نتعرف
على ايضا الاجراءات ايضا هل يعاني احد
منهم من حالات صحيه عمليه تجهيز
سواء علامه السفينه او حتى
على الارض
نعم سوف سوف تتضح معي الان الصوره بشكل
افضل عن اذا ما كان هناك اصابات او ايضا
حالات صحيه طبعا
لاول مره نصعد على سفينه عسكريه هنديه
ونرصد عمليه الاجلاء وكذلك رعايه الهند
هذه هي الصوره الواضحه بالنسبه
ممن قدموا من الهند وهنا ايضا سوف يكون
لوزير الدوله للشؤون الخارجيه كلمه طبعا
هي كلمه باللغه الاردنيه هو يحييهم على
سلامه وصولهم وكذلك يحييهم على عمليه
وصولهم خلينا خلينا شوي مع صوت الطبيعي
هاني اذا تكرمت
خلينا نسمع صوت طبيعي
[موسيقى]
مضطرون الى العوده لانه طبعا
طيب
هاني المكرونه الى العوده الى الرصيف هناك
طبعا يجب ان ناخذ اذن لمن هو يصعد على ظهر
السفينه طبعا لم ناخذ الاذن الكامل خاصه
ان هذه السفينه هي سفينه
من هنديه ويجب ان ناخذ الاذن من القبطان
او الكابتن كابتن السفينه
فبلاقونا ان نغادر قليلا حتى يتم تجهيز من
الداخل وبعد ذلك يتم المشاهده الوضع العام
او الشكل العام
للركاب عند نزولهم على الرصيف من جده
الاسلامي لكن بينما ايضا تقوم او يتم
انهاء كلمه وزير الدوله للشؤون الخارجيه
الهندي وهو يتحدث مع
ممن قدموا من السودان وجمعهم من الجنسيه
الهنديه
نتحدث ايضا عن الاستعدادات وهناك ايضا
لوجستيه وكذلك خدمات حكوميه تقوم بها
اجهزه الدوله وقطاعه امنيه في مقدمتهم
ايضا هناك وزاره الداخليه السعوديه وكذلك
وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه وايضا القطاعات
الامنيه التابعه لهذه لوزاره الداخليه او
كذلك لوزاره الدفاع او كذلك الجهات او
منسوبي وموظفي الخارجيه السعوديه طبعا
هناك تفاصيل التفاصيل التي قد لا يشعر
فيها البعض ولكنها تبقى من الامور المهمه
مثل توفير الحافلات ومثل ايضا تجهيز
الفنادق وكذلك عمليه انتقال ومنح
التاشيرات ايضا منهج التاشيرات هذه هذه
بالنسبه
[موسيقى]
لمن من الجنسيات الذين قدموا الى السعوديه
لا بد من حصولهم على التاشيرات في دول
العالم وفي نظام العالمي لا يسمح باي شخص
قوله الى اي بلد الا بتا الدخول وهنا تعطى
هذه التاشيره بشكل طارئ وشكل عادي
بالمجان فقط فتره بسيطه وبعد ذلك يتم
انهاء اجراءات لمغادرته الى بلاده وعودته
الى بلاده هاني ماذا عن
خطط هل هناك ايضا قطع عسكريه هنديه قد
تجلي بعض رعاياها هل من ارقام ربما موجوده
لاعدادهم هل تحدثتم الى المسؤولين الهنود
هل هناك ترتيبات ايضا مع يعني السلطات
السعوديه لاجل العمليات اجلاء قادمه
طيب عمليات الاجلاء طبعا دعني اتحدث لك من
اول يوم تم فيه عمليه اجلاء عبر السفينه
سعوديه قادمه من السودان وكان على متنها
قرابه الثلاثمائه شخص كانت سفينه واحده في
اليوم التالي اصبحت سفينتين اليوم الذي
بعد انتقل العدد الى خمس سفن وكذلك عمل
ايضا في الجهه الاخرى قاعده الملك عبد
الله الجويه والتي قامت
بجسر جوي هناك في عمليات اجلاء اذا
الوتيره ارتفعت في اليوم الذي بعده شهدنا
هنا ثلاث فرقاطات او ثلاث سفن
وبعدها في المساء ايضا اتت سفينتين
عسكريتين وراينا ايضا واكبنا ايضا السفينه
الفرنسيه او الفرقاط الفرنسيه
لورين التي كانت تحمل 400 شخص من من
البعثه او من البعثه الامم المتحده اذا
الاعداد تزداد وايضا السفن تزداد وكذلك
الجسر الجوي عدد رحلاته يوميا في ازدياد
شهود اعيان الذين تحدثنا معهم والذين
قدموا من السودان قالوا اذا كان يوميا
يغادر الف من السودان هناك الالاف لم
تستطيع الوصول او لم تستطع المغادره وكذلك
اذا كان هناك الف شخص يغادر السودان
باتجاه مدينه جده في عمليات الاجلاء فان
ياتي بعدهم ايضا الف اضافه الاعداد
الالفيه الاخرى اذا اعداد ممن يرغب في
الهرب بسبب النزاع القائم هناك في السودان
العدد كثير لا يوجد رقم حقيقي ولكن هذا
هذه الاعداد بحسب شهود عيان السؤال الاخر
ايضا الذي طرحناه على السيد الطيب ادم وهو
ممثل الامم المتحده للطفوله والذي قلنا له
كم اعداد النازحين وخاصه ان بعثه الامم
المتحده الان تعودنا دائما عليها
هي من تقوم بعمليات الاجلاء في مناطق
الصراعات والمناطق المنكوبه والان تقوم
هذه الفرقاطه الفرنسيه وايضا طلبتم من
الحكومه السعوديه عمليات اجلاء لموظفيكم
فقال لي انه لا يمكن حصر الاعداد عدد ممن
يرغبون باللجوء ولا نستطيع السير في داخل
السودان بسبب صعوبه الامر
بداء الرعايه بالنزول هاني اليكس كذلك
صحيح نعم نعم نعم بدل الان هذا وزير
الدوله لشؤون الخارجيه الهنديه هو نزل
وايضا اعضاء بعثتي التي ترافقه والان سوف
تبدا اول عمليه انزال ولكن البروتوكول
المعروف دائما
يقوم بالنزول السلك العسكري وبعد ذلك يعطى
السماح لباقي الرعايه
للنزول على الرصيف او داخل الاراضي
السعوديه على افيمنا
الاسلامي الان هذا اول طبعا البروتوكول
يبدا نزول الكابتن او طاقم
السفينه يكون في اسفل او على الرصيف حتى
يتم تمهيد لنزول اول الواصلين هذا هو اول
الواصلين الان من رعايه الهند الى
السعوديه
[ضحك]
الكل هنا يحييه وايضا هناك قائد وحده امن
المطار في حرس الحدود يتم تهنيته ايضا
والترحيب
هنا التحايا والتسليمات والابتسامات ايضا
من قبل
من قبل رعايه الهند الكل لم يكن يتوقع
وواضح ايضا الارهاق وايضا الجهد الذي كان
على مسافه السفر طبعا لا ننسى ايضا هناك
بالنسبه
لمركبات الاسعاف داخل ميناء جده الاسلامي
فهو يتواجد اجهزه الدفاع المدني ايضا
تتواجد للحالات الطارئه لا سمح الله لكن
حتى الان لم تصلنا او لم ترد اي حالات
اصابه تحملها هذه السفينه سواء اصابات من
جراء
النزاعات التي تحدث او الاصابات البليغه
بسبب النزاعات التي تحدث الان في السودان
او كذلك الاصابات الط التي قد حدثت لاشخاص
سواء هناك في السودان او ايضا علامه
السفينه في الجهه الاخرى نعم مركبات
الاسعاف ولكن حتى الان ممن ينزلونهم اشخاص
السليمون سليمين يعني ومعافين
بكل صحه وسلامه وهم ايضا السعاده كما ذكرت
انها تغمرهم طبعا هذا العدد الاجمالي الان
مع او الاعداد الاجماليه الان من رعايه
الهند التي قامت بحملهم فرقاطات السفن
العسكريه الهنديه فقط يقارب ال800 شخص مع
هذه الدفعه يتوقع ايضا وصول دفعه او سفينه
عسكريه اخرى هنديه يوم اليومين القادمين
ولكن ما زلنا نتابعها ايضا هناك سفن
عسكريه سوف تصل اليوم سواء من الصين او
ايضا من كوريا الصين يوم امس كانت هناك
سفينتين متزامنتين وصلتا الى ميناء جدا
يتوقع ان تصل اليوم سفينه صينيه ثالثه وقد
ايضا يكون بعدها سفينه
كوريه عسكريه اخرى طبعا
فقط السفن التي نتحدث عنها والتي تصل من
جدا الاسلامي هي فقط تحمل رعاياها لا تحمل
اي جنسيات اخرى بخلاف ايضا ما تقوم به
القوات البحريه الملكيه السعوديه هناك في
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه والتي تحمل
رعايه من جنسيات مختلفه في بيانات الرسميه
التي خرجت بها السعوديه واعلنت عنها ان
عدد او اجمالي ما وصل الى السعوديه من من
نقلتهم القوات البحريه الملكيه السعوديه
حتى الان اكثر من 2500 شخص من 69 دوله من
69 الجنسيه تحديدا اذا تسعه وستين الجنسيه
من 2015 مقابل 2500 شخص لن ننسى ايضا هناك
قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه وتحديدا هذه
القاعده الجويه التي يوميا تغادر وتقلع
منها طائرات متجهه الى السودان سواء
طائرات سعوديه او كذلك طائرات من دول
اجنبيه واتخذت قائده الملك عبد الله
الجويه في جده كمحطه وقوف للتعبئه وكذلك
تريث
ملاحي الطائره وبعدها يتم مغادرتهم طبعا
مده الرحله دائما الطائره بين السعوديه
واو كذلك بتحديد الطائرات العسكريه قرابه
40 الى 45 دقيقه الى بورت سودان وبعد ذلك
يتم اجلاء الرعايه في حديثنا ايضا امس مع
قائد قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه اللواء
طيار ركن عبد الله الزهراني والذي تحدث
للعربيه ان عندنا سؤالنا هل المطار يسمح
هناك بالنزول الطائرات الضخمه والكبيره
فقال ان المهبط او مدرج الطائرات الموجود
هناك هي للطائرات القصيره هي او مدرج
الطائره ليس بالطول الكافي فيتم فقط
مغادره الطائرات العسكريه اسرع وكذلك هي
كمسافات قصيره ومناسبه وملائمه للطائرات
العسكريه اكثر من الطائرات الكبيره
المدنيه في عمليه الاجراءات يتم بشكل اسرع
وتتم بشكل ايضا مغادره افضل وكذلك ايضا في
لا سمح الله في عمليات الامنيه او اذا حدث
طارق تكون خروجها من السودان بشكل اسرع
وافضل اذا عمليات الانزال ما زلنا نشاهده
هنا على سفينه
السفينه العسكريه الهنديه بدا شاهدنا الان
سيدات من الهند وهن يبتسم وسعيدات بوصولهن
الى بر الامان هم يريدون فقط الامان
والسلام
وهذه سيده اخرى ايضا ومعها ايضا ثقه سيده
وهنا ايضا دفعه اخرى نتحدث عن هذه الدفعه
مره اخرى للتذكير للساده الذين الان
يحضرون على شاشه العربيه والتي ترصد وصول
سفينه عسكريه هنديه الى ميناء جده
الاسلامي وهي احدى السفن العسكريه
الاجنبيه التي تصل السعوديه ولا تحمل على
متنها
326 من رعايه الهند قدموا من بورت سودان
الى منى جده الاسلامي وبعد ذلك يتم نقله
عبر حافلات مخصصه لانهاء اجراءاتهم
وتوجههم الى مقر اقامتهم في جده نعم عادل
هل خلال الايام الماضيه وحديثكم مع من تم
اجلائهم هل تحدثوا عن المعاناه التي
يعانونها لغايه الوصول الى بورت سودان محل
انطلاقاتهم حتى وصولهم الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه بامان
القصص كثيره وفعلا هو هذا وهو سؤال مهم
كنا نتحدث يوم امس مع عدد من الجاليات
العربيه والجنسيات العربيه ونتحدث تحديدا
عن الجنسيه
اجرينا لقاء مع احد الجنسيات العربيه
وابلغنا قلت كيف كان الوضع عند خروجك
الامر السهل او الصعب قال ان كي اصل من
الخرطوم الى بورت سودان احتاج الى خمسه
عشر ساعه حتى اصل ايضا عندما اصل الى
النادي الموانع هناك الذي يتجمع في الكل
هناك ليطلب النجاه نحتاج نظل اربعه الى
سته ايام هناك بعض السفرات الدول تتعاون
معنا ولكن كانت سفاره السعوديه الكل كان
يتحدث تحديدا ويشيد بجهود السفاره
السعوديه هناك التي منحت الفرصه ممن يرغب
بالذهاب الى السعوديه وبعد ذلك
يتم التنسيق مع سفارته من اجل مغادره الى
بلاده فالكل كان يستجيب بعض سفرات الدول
المهتمه برعاياها مثل الان من شاهد
السفينه العسكريه الهنديه فقد اهتمت
برعاياها ايضا هناك السفينه الصينيه يوم
امس كانت تحمل عدد من رايه كانت تهتم
برعايا ولكن يحملون فقط ابناء بلدتهم او
ابناء جلدتهم هم من يحملونهم فقط لا
يحملون اي جنسيه اخرى ايضا بالنسبه
للطائرات العسكريه يوم امس ايضا كان هناك
طائر عسكريه هنديه وكانت تحمل فقط 150 شخص
من رعايه الهند فقط هم ثلاث اشخاص الذين
يحملون او بالاصح 123 شخص فقط ثلاث اشخاص
من ال123 شخص هم من الجنسيه السودانيه
ويعملون في القنصليه الفرنسيه فكانت وساطه
القنصليه الفرنسيه مع السفاره الهنديه ومع
القنصل هناك هو من استطاع من سمحوا بثلاثه
اشخاص الغير جنسيه الهنديه يصعدون على هذه
الطائره بخلاف ما تقوم به القوات البحريه
الملكيه السعوديه او كذلك القوات الجويه
الملكيه السعوديه التي تحمل رعايه من
جنسيات مختلفه وصلت الى 69 شخص في جانب
اخر ايضا في حديثنا مع القنصل العام
الاندونيسي يوم امس وفي لقاء اجريناه تحدث
ان عدد الجاليه الاندونيسيه الموجوده في
السودان يبلغون الف شخص وصل منهم الى
السعوديه
738 شخصا غادر من هؤلاء العدد ال78 شخص
285 والمتبقون سوف يغادرون الى بلادهم
طبعا غادروا من جده الى بلادهم الى جاكرتا
العدد المتبقي سوف يتم اجلاءه من السودان
خلال اليومين القادمين على دفعتين
الطائره اندونيسيه سوف تكون او طائره
عسكريه اندونيسيه سوف تكون من بورت سودان
الى
قائده الملك عبد الله في جده طبعا هذا كان
حديث السفراء وكان هؤلاء او كان ايضا حديث
القناص القنصل الاندونيسي الموجود في في
السعوديه او في مدينه جده تحديدا طبعا
اللقاءات كثيره والاحاديث كثيره ولكن
بينما هو الحديث واللقاءات سوف اغادر الى
زاويه اخرى سوف اغادر الى زاويه اخرى الى
الحافلات
الحافلات هنا يتم نقل
الان رايه الهند الى الحافلات ونشاهد كيف
عمليه توجههم الى الحافلات وعمليه الترتيب
التي نفذتها الخارجيه السعوديه وهذه ايضا
الاحاديث التي كنت تتحدث بها معك عزيزي
عادل وايضا مشاهدي قناه العربيه التفاصيل
الصغيره التي قد تغيب في بعض الاحيان حتى
في المطارات الطبيعيه حتى لو كنت سائح
ايضا قد لا تجد ايضا في اثناء ذهابك في
جروب سياحيه قد لا تجد الراحه في ايصالك
الى الفندق بشكل جيد ولكن دعنا نشاهد هذه
الحافله الان التي وفرتها الخارجيه
السعوديه وايضا هي عده حافلات كل شخص او
كل حافله تحمل قرابه 42 شخص هذه الدفعه
الاولى بالنسبه للحافله
امامنا حافله وايضا اخرى او حافله اخرى
ثالثه في في بعد الحافله الثانيه نشاهد
الحافله من الداخل طبعا هذا اكتمل الصف
ولكن نقترب قليلا مع المصور الذي يعطينا
صوره مختلفه طبعا هناك اكتمل العدد فيقوم
او يقومون بالنزول للتوجه الى
العدد الاخر باي
سوف نقوم بالدخول
يقترب المصور قليلا
اقترب طبعا احنا حافله مجهزه سواء
بالاشياء البسيطه مثل المياه وكذلك مكيفه
ولكن سوف ندع الصوره هي التي تلتقط ما هو
حل الحافله هذه حافله قرابه 42 شخص الان
هم وصلوا بسلام يقومون الان هؤلاء الاشخاص
بالتوجه الى التاشيرات او منصات الجوازات
لمنحهم تاشيره دخول وهي تاشيره دخول طارئه
وبعد ذلك يتجه الى مقر اقامته في مدينه
جده في فندق معد لا هناك طبعا خمس فنادق
رصدناها في اليومين الماضيين وكذلك سوف
نرصدها خلال اليوم
لمشاهده ايضا عمليه سكن هؤلاء سواء لرايه
الهند او كذلك الجنسيات الاخرى التي تاتي
الى السعوديه وكيف
كيف كيف ايضا تقوم او يقومون
بالسكني في اماكن جيده حتى يتم انهاء
اجراء مغادراتهم الى الهند هذه الصوره
العامه السفينه ما زلنا نشاهد اعداد
الرايه ولكن توقف الطابور في الاعلام حتى
يتم انزال الدفعه الاولى وتم انزال الدفعه
الاولى حتى لا يكون هناك تدافع او ازدحام
وتكون العمليه منظمه وبعد ذلك ايضا
يتوجهون كما ذكرت الى الحافله ولو نعود
قليلا كي تتضح الصوره بشكل
اذا تكرمت انا يعني حتى الزميل المصور
يعطينا المشاهد اكثر عما يحدث
لديك نحن نتحدث عن على مدى هذه الايام كما
اشار الزميل هاني صفيان مراسل العربيه الى
800 شخص من رعايه الهند كانوا قد وصلوا
الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه وتم اجلائهم
على مدى هذه الايام من السودان وتحديدا من
بورتسودان وصلوا عبر فرقاطات هنديه سمحت
لهم المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بالوصول الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في
جده ومن ثم الى هذا الميناء ايضا
وصول العديد من من تم اجلائهم من السودان
خاصه في ظل التصاعد حدث الاشتباكات بين
قوات الجيش والدعم السريع
ونحن الان في هدنه هدنه الاثنين وسبعين
ساعه التي انطلقت عند الساعه الثانيه عشره
بالتوقيت المحلي
للخرطوم وبالتالي تمهيدا لاجلاء الرعايه
هاني هذه ليست الدفعه الاخيره هناك دفعات
اخرى علامات هذه الفرقه
العسكريه
الهنديه تحمل
برعاياها كما اشرنا
من رعايه الهند في السودان تم اجناؤهم
تفضل هاني
صحيح نعم نعم طبعا
ساعود لك بالتفصيل الذي وردا على سؤالك
ايضا في موضوع
الدفعات الاخرى ولكن سوف نلتقط الدفعه
الان التي تقوم بالنزول الان ايضا او
تستكمل عمليه النزول ولكن هناك شخص يتحدث
اللغه العربيه
السودان
ان شاء الله
لن ينسى السودان كما قالوا انه عمل هناك
هو يعني
لمديره ولكن عمليه الانزال طبعا نحاول ان
نجد احد يتحدث معنا اللغه العربيه كي ينقل
بالتفصيل التفصيل اذا كانت هناك
هذه التغطيه المباشره معك من حيث انت راح
نعطيك المجال بالتاكيد للبحث عن من يتحدث
اللغه العربيه او حتى تستطيع الحديث مع اي
من المتحدثين اعرف انك لا تعرف لا تجيد
الاردن ولكن اكيد بالانجليزي شكرا جزيلا
لك هانس فيان لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات